Hey everybody.
What the fuck is going on.
This is one of the very last versions of the Joe Rogan questions everything
podcasts that we're releasing as an actual podcast.
We did somewhere around 10 of them and I think we have two left.
So probably this one and one other one might not have been 10 but don't get all
specific.
Ladies and gentlemen this show was really a pleasure to do the.
The big pleasure of it was working with my buddy Duncan of course and exposing
him to millions of people worldwide who didn't didn't know about my brilliant
friend and one of things I really love about doing podcast with Duncan is he
really gets me inspired to go on these wild rants and I think I inspire him in
the same way and we have this really cool give and take energy when it comes to
certain things and he was just absolutely brilliant on the show and in
introducing subjects and talking to people and injecting new ideas into these
silly subjects like psychics which is this this episode and a huge thank you to
Benishek who was the guy who we interviewed during the show and had him put on a
little bit of a demonstration that really opened up my mind to what is possible
in the world of trickery and manipulation and sleight of hand the art thereof of
it.
I mean I'd always known that there was a real art to magic but boy did that guy
blow my mind.
And what are the things I really appreciated about battered check was that he
blew my mind and then he told me it was all bullshit.
He didn't try to pretend that he had some magic power or some device that only
the government knows about hidden horseshit you.
He told you after he was doing that.
And even during the time he was doing it that it was all bullshit but he was so
good at it it was still unbelievably fascinating.
I hope this also opens up a lot of people's eyes as to what is possible in terms
of trickery in terms of what someone can what someone can trick you into
believing and what kind of manipulation people can pull off when they pretend to
have psychic abilities.
There's a lot of that going on folks.
There's I mean there very well may be some sort of a psychic energy that people
possess whether it's a sense that people are not aware of or smells that people
can detect that they can't quite describe that aren't quite olfactory but to
some sense of something being wrong.
But there's also a lot of liars out there man.
There's a lot of fakers and there's a lot of bullshit.
And one of the things that I was most proud about the sci fi show was that we
were able to expose some of that bullshit and whether it was bullshit about the
science behind chem trails or whether it was the evidence in quotes when it
comes to UFOs or whether it was not bullshit like the that the technical and
technological innovation that's going on at this incredibly rapid rate that
we're experiencing and where this all could lead to.
You know it was one of my favorite parts about the show in fact.
One of the least controversial and most real aspects of the show.
But ultimately it was a lot of fun to do.
And so thank you to Duncan Trussell and Duncan has an amazing podcast that
Duncan Trussell family hour.
He's an amazing standup comedian.
He's just one of my favorite human beings on the planet.
He and Chris Ryan who is the author of Sex at Dawn and me are doing a joint
podcast once a month.
We just did Duncans really recently that Duncan Trussell family our and we doing
Chris Ryan's podcast podcast which is tangentially speaking.
And then I will do mine again and we'll just keep rotating once a month we'll do
each other.
But just awesome to have those guys as friends.
Awesome to be able to do this show with Duncan and awesome to be able to work
with such awesome guys like Tom Mesereau who is the executive producer and and
Frank and Michael from Arthur Smith and just we had a great time and all the
people at Sci fi Tim and Wayne and everyone thank you very much.
We really really enjoyed working with you guys and I really appreciate the
opportunity and I really appreciate you letting me release these podcasts that
we recorded on the show.
A lot of people thought they were like we were faking podcasts they were
actually real podcasts and allegedly there was real marijuana involved.
Anyway this is one of the last ones and this one is brought to you by Ting Ting
is a cell phone service that utilizes the sprint backbone.
It's one of my favorite all time podcast sponsors because I have had nothing but
positive feedback from Ting Ting is the cell phone service if you've heard us
talk about it before that uses Top End and phones and what they do is they rent
space off of the off the sprint backbone so they do it on their terms like they
don't have any contracts they don't have any early termination fees they don't
have all the nonsense that a lot of people have that's attached to his cell
phone service it's like hidden fees and overages with Tang you only pay for what
you use if you go over your allotted minutes you just pay for what you use is
not some exorbitant rate that you have to pay for it's not some some go fuck
yourself nonsense that comes along because that's that's a real problem with a
lot of these companies that are selling cell phone services that they're greedy
they don't just want a little bit they want it all they want to suck you dry and
get out of you whatever they can get out of you What team does is they sell you
the very best of all of the Android phones like the Samsung Galaxy Note 3 which
is what I use or they use the the Galaxy S4 which is another suite phone the HTC
One there's a bunch of these really bad ass Android phones and they do it in a
way where you are going to save money guaranteed you're going to save it because
98 percent of people 98 percent people would save money would tank if you're one
of those 2 percent MAN YOU NEED TO LOOK AT YOURSELF WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU DUDE
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU MAN.
Why are you saving money.
Hmm hmm hmm hmm.
Are you a crazy with how you use your phone.
What's wrong man.
What is wrong with you.
Most people save.
I know Chris Ryan uses it.
He saves.
I know.
It's just it's all in all a better way to do business.
And again no contracts.
If you want to leave you just leave.
You have to deal with any fucking nonsense.
You don't have to deal with any of the bullshit that you deal with a regular
cell phone networks.
And again you use really awesome cell phones.
So
what is that.
You are hell.
I can't find it.
I got updated copied.
They want me to say some things not broken is it.
You know why do I feel like it's different.
I just wanna make sure it's okay.
Hold on folks.
This is not much of an advertising here.
Rogan Dr. income
is that it.
Yes.
Okay.
Go to Rogan debt to income and you'll save twenty five dollars off any of their
new Android phones a device.
I couldn't recommend them enough.
They're an ethical company and they're a company that's trying to do what I wish
all companies would do.
What I wish all companies would do was try to make money but don't try to make
all the fucking money.
I mean isn't it possible that you can you know make a little bit less money and
not have people fucking pissed off at you.
So go to Rogan DOT team dot com and enjoy their mobile company.
That makes sense.
It's a no bullshit mobile service.
They say B.S.
and a copy I say bullshit OK.
You can call them their customer support at 1 8 5 5 10 FTE w they use internet
speak like ting for the win.
Don't you love that.
And they have online support and helped out tame dot.com.
So go to Rogan dotting dot com.
Save yourself some cash.
Ash were also brought to you by hove or hove or is it's actually hover hover as
a domain name company that I use myself.
Hover hover while I call it hover I'm fucking asshole.
That's why I've been using hover for over a year now.
I've registered several domains with Hover it's super easy to do and hover has
it set up where you get things for free like who is domain name services hover
is actually owned by the same people that own tanks so the same ethics sort of
applies to hover that applies to tank trying to give you a good service at a
reasonable rate where you could feel good about the transaction and that really
should be what business is all about they should give you something where you
pay for it what you feel like it's worth and then you get the bill at the end of
the month.
Oh well that was worth that and that that's possible.
OK it can be like that and you don't get that with early termination fees and
all that shit.
They're taking advantage of you.
Fucking man hover gives you exactly what you need to get the job done you find
the perfect domain name for your idea to live so you can get started on it and
move on to the next thing on your to do list.
Know why they even have a copy.
Don't tell me what to do.
I know about my to do list you fucks but if you're looking for the great place
the best place for a domain geeks developers designers and programs are always
talking about hover and even people like me.
I guess somebody's a geek very uneducated geek but Harvard gives you easy to use
powerful tools tools to manage your domain and they also make it very easy to
import your domain over to hover.
They they actually called a valet transfer the people that hover are experts at
domain so you don't have to be.
They just want to take all the friction out of managing your domains and they
want you to be able to manage them all in one place.
So they offer you a valet transfer service to make it as easy as possible to
move your domains hover.
Also also offers Google Apps for Your domains which is pretty sweet to have on
you can just set it up from hover.
Really easy to do.
Super intuitive interface and hover has outstanding customer support because
Google is a huge company and pretty much impossible to get a hold of if you ever
need a hand.
They can do it through hover they can help you with your Google Apps and you can
try 30 days of Google apps on your domain for free at hover to see if you'd like
it
so these days Ladies Gentlemen it makes sense to get your own unique email
address and they can do that and hover as well.
Personal professional and cooler than your Hotmail or your AOL.
You still have AOL.
You're a fool.
You're not going to fucking get my business.
Contact me.
Johnny shit pants at AOL dot com.
Works at AOL what.
So you never have to switch e-mails and send one of those Hey everyone I got a
new email to everyone on your contact lists that you hate that shit.
And an email from hover is one that you'll won't outgrow.
It's easy to remember.
It's portable.
You can switch away from your email provider without losing your email address.
So go to her over.
Ladies and gentlemen hover dot com and you can use the code word Bigfoot.
This for this episode it's Bigfoot.
Use the code word Bigfoot and save yourself some cash.
Why Bigfoot.
Well because we're trying to look see like how many people pay attention to
which episode and which one is more effective.
So to save some money the promo code for this episode is Bigfoot use it and go
fuck yourself.
Don't go fuck yourself I don't really mean that I say that shit but I'm just
trying to be silly.
I'm just trying to give you a little levity before you delve into the world of
fake psychics.
So with that without any further ado thank you very much for tuning into the
podcast.
Thank you very much for all the love online and Twitter and so many people that
I've met that tell me they appreciate the podcast and I appreciate the fuck out
of you guys as well.
And if not for all the information that a lot of you tweet to me and send me on
Facebook and things people tell me about when I meet them I mean we are in a
very strange time ladies and gentlemen and we are sharing information and I am
merely a conduit to do to distribute some of that information your way.
And I'm honored and I'm out of here.
So enjoy the podcast and because
it's will gain experience by.
So this podcast is about psychics
and maybe the lack thereof.
You know at a certain point time in the show.
You got it.
I was wondering what exactly was going on when it came to psychics.
I always wondered.
I mean I would never want to completely discredit the possibility that someone
could have some extraordinary power that I don't possess.
Who knows.
You know I mean in a way it's been explained.
McKenna described communication as a form of telepathy talking because in a way
you're you're making established sounds with your mouth that are attached to a
cultural context that we all sort of agree to.
And in doing so you're reading my mind.
I'm talking to you.
You know what I'm I'm talking about a laptop.
I went to the store to get my laptop fixed and the guy behind the counter was in
such a nice guy.
You were you're experiencing that with me you know so you're sort of like
getting a version of my memories.
And so I never wanted to like completely say oh it's all b.s.
there's no way but man as we do the show like The more we did it at a certain
point Tom I was like how much of this is fucking free you know how much of this
is kooky.
There was there were several times we were doing the show where else.
Like Paul Smith who seemed like a very nice guy tried to get me to a remote view
and I had nothing screw a bunch of stuff down on paper and he was like Just go
to with whatever is moving you know just like there's nothing there.
I honestly maybe it's just me.
I mean I left it to me.
I'm like I want to see him do it because you know he'd been doing it for more
than a decade.
He's an expert at and he's actually had positive results with it but me trying
it.
They were saying that they could show me how to do it within X amount of minutes
I would be doing it right.
Nothing I wrote.
I drew some stuff that I drew like a square and I wrote the color red and
something was square with red in it but it was I guess it was a dumb guess it
was a guest where there was a bunch of shapes and stuff in this location.
So if I had to judge myself on a pass or fail I would give myself a ninety nine
point nine nine percent fail.
I can't say 100 percent fail because I did have a square that had red in it and
there was something like that.
It seems to me to be like something that shows up a lot.
Look there's this hour on air sign it's a rectangle that has red in it.
I mean it's like there's a lot of squares with red and I'm Yeah.
So I think that easily could have been nonsense.
So but then I talked to Ed dames okay and he's the number one top dog.
If you start Google and like people that are able to do that.
People that have that remote viewing skill Ed dames name comes up like
immediately.
He's like the godfather of this stuff.
He started that Stargate program.
You know so he was working on remote viewing.
He said they had really positive result.
He said he knows how to do it.
And he said that they found Osama bin Laden and he actually said they found
Osama bin Laden.
He believes they didn't go after him because they didn't want to end the war yet
for whatever reason you know.
So take that for you know the grain of salt whatever.
Maybe he's right.
But now you do take something like that with a grain of salt like he's saying
that psychics saw Osama bin Laden who did they call go how does that
conversation go down.
Hey what's that.
Well he's not to psychics he's working for the CIA.
He's in the government.
He's working in the government right.
I mean he's he's been.
And he said also in this I found this kind of interesting and kind of make
sense.
He said that they were trying to like distance themselves from this program
because it's like this paranormal thing like you're working on like psychics.
And he was like even if it was effective they were like look we don't want to be
connected to that because it just sounds too loony even if it's effective.
Well you know what man.
If you look at the history of the various experiments the CIA have done.
They're not afraid of loony right they were dumping acid into a guy's mouth and
brothels with to a windows.
You see the effects of LSD.
Once you've done that you'll do anything for folks who don't know that story.
It was called the operation midnight climax.
And what they did was they they bought brothels in New York and in San
Francisco.
And these guys they came in to engage in you know prostitution type activities
and they dosed them.
They dosed them with LSD.
Yeah.
And it's an amazing story because the guys can say shit you know you're not
supposed to be in a whorehouse anyway and you're out there and you're getting
dosed up with acid like Yikes Holy shit.
They did a lot more than that man.
A lot more than that they went in a mental asylum.
And they doped people up so much that they tried to rewrite their memories to
fix their their various mental disorders.
They wanted to see if they could or right erase memories.
They're doing this to mentally ill people in mental hospitals.
I'll look it up.
Project Monarch.
The whole point is the CIA is not afraid of putting their feet and crazy river.
They do it all the time.
So I think that the idea that they there is they stopped this thing because they
don't want to embarrass themselves.
No they stopped it because it wasn't working because let me tell you.
Okay but let's let's for a moment before I stop you I just want to play devil's
advocate okay.
All of those things that we're mentioning are in the past.
Operation midnight climax believes in the 1950s.
Yeah the this remote viewing movement.
They stopped.
That is well.
Is it possible and again this is just devil's advocate that they try things and
they don't work so they move on.
Is that possible.
Is it possible that they it's it's just that it didn't work.
I mean I think that if any government on the planet figured out a way to use a
team of elite psychics to locate their enemies right.
They're not gonna be like oh let's cancel this program it's embarrassing they're
gonna keep using it because it's effective.
What's a better thing than you've just set some guy in a chair and have him
communicate all over the planet with whatever matrix of intelligence exist
between him and whatever.
Okay.
What if it only works every now and then but sometimes it really does work.
I think there's plenty of money in the government to keep somebody like that on
tap but maybe not man.
I think it does work.
I've had so many moments where I'm thinking of a friend and they call or I'll
get a weird feeling about somebody and something bad will happen to them and I
know plenty of people who do that and I know plenty of people who will get
around certain people and immediately not be comfortable around them and they're
sensing something about that person.
I think animals are always tuning into this deeper instinctual level so at some
point it just becomes I think semantics.
Some people are gonna say well I just listen to my instincts.
Some people are going to say that their psychic so I don't think that there is a
it's too out there to think that there's some people who have especially
developed instincts where they're really good at tuning in to watch Sheldrake
call the more for genetic field.
I think that's possible that you could do that.
The problem is well if you if it is possible then how come it can't be or
reproduced in laboratory settings.
And a lot of people say that immediately discounts it but man I I can't imagine
meeting someone who's never had that moment where you think about someone and
suddenly they call someone that you haven't talked to in years.
You know that that has happened now.
To play devil's advocate again Sam Harris says that all that is is coincidental
and that we think about people all the time and they don't call but occasionally
you think about people and they do call and then it really is just dumb luck.
But we make it out to be this big important moment and we sort of discredit all
the other times where it failed.
But he's like really super logical when it comes to stuff like that to the point
where I almost have to step back like he said that statistically no one really
ever gets a hot hand in basketball where they can't miss it just seems like they
do.
But if you count up statistically like there's never a zone for where there's an
unusual amount of activity over a course of an hour it's like these little
bursts where things are really good and then they go away but it all balances
itself out in the end.
And I've found it found that very fascinating cause I've always felt like
someone getting in the zone whether it's in golf or in pool or in basketball or
anything.
I always thought that was a real thing and some people I've seen pool players do
it when you get into a place where you just can't miss.
And you know you just find that zone and you're significantly better than when
you're not in that zone right.
So I've always felt that it was a real thing.
So Sam Harris is a tricky guy when it comes to his ideas on these things.
Well who knows man.
Maybe he hasn't experienced it himself but maybe he has and he's analyzed it
more objectively than you and I am.
That's a possibility too.
I had a dream once where in the dream this girl that I was engaged to be married
came up to me and said hey I'm pregnant and in the dream I was bummed out.
I'm like Oh great.
Pregnant and then the next day I woke up and an hour after I woke up she called
to tell me that she's getting married now.
Wow.
What is that.
Well I know that that happened to me and I know that every night I don't dream
about my ex fiancee being pregnant.
That's not a recurring dream if it were I would be in therapy.
Is she getting married because she's pregnant.
No.
But.
OK well then that doesn't see that's where I would step in as a skeptic.
Not necessarily.
I'm not really a skeptic but if I was I would say because I kind of am sometimes
I would say you probably think about her all the time I think about my exes all
the time.
It's like a normal part of life.
Yeah.
I don't you're you you were engaged.
Sure.
And I've vivid dreams I understand that.
But you were engaged to her.
That's a very strong connection with someone it's very likely that you bring her
up in your mind on occasion.
I have your scenario on my stomach.
Your scenario is different than her scenario your scenario is she was pregnant
her scenario the reality was that she was getting married.
Well you just happen to be thinking about her and she just happened to call you
and tell you that she's getting married and you have made this grandiose
connection between a dream.
Well let me play the real devil's advocate because as many Christians know the
devil is the advocate of psychics the psychics say that what actually happens is
that your mind is kind of like scanning and it doesn't always accurately
interpret the event.
So pregnancy and marriage that go hand in hand and then she did end up having
children.
So the the point what makes it special and by the way I don't I know what Sam
Harris is talking about.
They've done studies about the idea that there's perpetually as just a vortex of
variables spinning through your mind that consist of all the people you know and
all the things that could happen and those things are mostly in the subconscious
but when something in the external universe happens that resonates with
something in the subconscious that creates the sense of synchronicity that you
say is real.
Yeah man I know that I don't always dream about it I know the dream was very
vivid I know it was like really soon after waking up to the point where when I
got off the phone I was like What the fuck.
That is really weird.
So well it is like it's not outside of the realm of possibility but all I ever
say in these situations is I try even though I am a natural dork and my natural
inclination is to believe in psychics.
My natural inclination is to believe in Bigfoot and aliens and UFOs and
everything.
But I also think that there's a benefit in considering the completely numerical
scientific approach you know in looking at how a guy like Sam Harris would look
out and go you know what you have to address that too why wouldn't you address
that.
You know we don't want to address that because we don't want to miss out on some
of the magic that is the world right and we'd like to think that in in being
able to tell when things are about to happen to you that somehow maybe that
offers you some veil of protection that other people don't enjoy.
You know and sometime with its shit is going to happen I'm not going to know not
to get on that plane.
You know and we would like to think that we would like to think that I know many
people miss planes and then the plane crashes and they swear they knew they
shouldn't get on that plane.
I mean there's probably a lot of that too.
I would if that happened I maybe I hadn't thought it I'd say I was going to get
on the plane maybe maybe we'd become a part of your consciousness maybe whether
you like it or not just enter in there.
Well yeah you know I like what Terence McKenna said about people you know
ancient humans and hunting and how you would have to develop the ability to
silently communicate with a group of people that you're hunting with.
It would make it it would make you very effective if as a hunter especially if
you're hunting in group situations where you had to stalk something.
Yes.
So in that way I could see how there might be a part of our brain that you can
develop to be acutely tuned in to what the people around you are thinking about
doing.
I think all sports teams are based on that.
I think that I'm sure that people who fight or you get in there really serious
situations will tell you that they can really tune in to every sound you hear
that when someone's in a situation where they have to fight or they're in a life
or death situation you always hear this.
Suddenly everything becomes very loud they can hear everything see everything.
So I think it makes sense that there is a deeper part of the human mind that is
more aware than the conscious part of the mind that makes sense.
I don't I don't.
I don't know if that's what psychics say that they're using but I think that
that does exist in the human mind.
It's also possible.
I think that there is like it's almost like a waterfall that we sort of can poke
our heads through and then pull it back and then we can't tune in all the time.
It's very ethereal it's very slippery.
Yeah and you get it or you don't get it and maybe some people get it better than
than we do.
But one of the things that I have to respectfully acknowledge is that Ed dames
who has done this for so long trains people and it was pretty clear to me that I
needed to learn it in order to really understand it and I didn't learn it and I
certainly didn't learn it from him.
I mean Paul taught it to me very quickly but it was really just for the show.
You know if we had spent a bunch of time together like over several weeks and I
really like tried to do it as if I was a prospect for one of their programs
maybe I could learn what the hell he was talking about maybe it's just my
silliness.
Maybe there was a breakthrough to be had that I didn't recognize it's super
possible that that's the case.
But you know there's all there's part of you for sure.
That's always gonna be skeptical until it's right and front of you.
Right.
And if you've experienced it then you have it.
You can be skeptical about the experience but you have to acknowledge the
experience.
Yeah.
No.
And then I went to the Rhine Institute.
Okay.
And this is really interesting.
That's the.
They're the place for the Scientific Study of the paranormal center.
And I had a great time there.
Who is the guy that ran the Ryan center.
John Cruyff.
John Carruth is the guy who ran the Ryan center and was kind enough to take us
through and show.
I sucked it over everything I tried to be psychic with the numbers like can
picking which button to press.
I try to be psychic with picking winners but in the process I screwed that up.
And but one thing I did do is they had this this room where it's totally dark
and they have this meter that measures photons and apparently you can create
some sort of light from your body some sort of set so some sort of photon
release that can be measured and the highest that anybody ever did it was this
guy IRL and this guy IRL was like if he was a character in a Will Ferrell movie
like he would be like the perfect cohort he'd be like Will Ferrell's crazy
partner who also happens to be psychic.
Yeah and he was trying to move me with his mind.
Ed what did I say his name was Will Earl.
He seems like it should be at Earl.
HIS NAME WAS ED Yeah.
Ed had gotten to one million on this thing and Ed also could make you weave back
and forth.
He could he could like direct you with his body and force force your body
backward and forward.
Or so he said he tried to do it.
I didn't move at all.
I don't know what he's talking about but I try.
I let him try it but he's gotten to a million on this photon thing.
I got to four hundred thousand which they were very shocked by but I had a
battery pack on my head.
I had a microphone and when I was doing it I was stretching so mean the battery
pack we had like tape over the light and everything like that.
But the bottom line is there's like a piece of electronics in the room sure.
We did it again and I got even though I got less much less than the first time I
basically did the same stuff I was doing.
I was most like leaning forward and touching my toes like stretching and stuff.
And I was also trying to breathe really hard as I was.
But then I thought about us like how is that psychic.
What am I doing even if I can glow you know like in a way that a human being
couldn't even perceive if you could like hold your breath to the point we
fucking glow or get tense up and scream to the point where you G.I.
until a spark comes out of your dick.
I don't know I don't know if that's possible but either way it's not psychic.
I mean there was nothing I did that gave me any inclination whatsoever that have
any psychic ability but I registered very highly on this one silly test.
Yeah while I was running a battery pack.
Yeah.
You know it's to be the battery.
I mean I think who knows man.
I don't know call them up the next day because he seem like an honest guy and
you know he was really excited about the results I said you know what I think we
screwed up.
Well I think we should have done one without the battery pack.
We did it twice to see if we could replicate it you know but this thing is still
on me and even though it's behind me and we're in this when it's totally dark
room I'm still wearing a battery pack and I'm moving around and I don't know if
Ed was doing the same things that I was doing.
So even though my score on this this thing was was higher I might have been
moving more than he was.
That might have been why the the light changed in the room wearing this little
battery pack so this wasn't really scientific test but if you look at the
evolution of animals right and you think about animals before eyeballs existed
the evolution of the eye.
You think about the gradual evolution of the eye.
Yeah.
There would be certain animals that were that mutation was happening to more
than other animals.
Yet those animals could talk and they started reporting to other animals Hey man
there is stuff all around us.
There are things swimming.
I've seeing reefs right.
That's if that the other animals like you are out of your mind there's this
darkness and movement that's all there is.
You're crazy.
So I don't think that it's an insane idea that our senses are continuing to
expand and to evolve right.
And if you think about what they used to be compared to what they are now we are
like gods compared to what we used to be.
You know when we are just tiny little lemur creatures eating each other's poop
and running from snakes all day that's a very good point.
But another point is if that is the case and we're pretty aware of the
established state of consciousness that exists right now without psychic ability
we're pretty sure that most of the time almost everywhere you go there's no
psychic ability going on it's just normal life but little peeps of it pop
through.
Yeah.
Every now and then almost like poking through a membrane finding its way
dissolving this membrane slowly but surely with new experiences all the time.
But the membranes gigantic because really what we're talking about is an
evolving ability and it takes a long ass time for a human being to evolve an
ability.
Right.
And you know some people though say that it's not an evolving ability it's a
devolving ability than we used to be more tuned into what was happening around
us.
But then technology took the place of that because really I don't need to be
telepathic I can send you a text through the air I don't need to be in a panic
but look at birds look at birds what they can do or look at.
Dogs.
I don't think that people think that you that we used to be able to do it
though.
Well I think the idea is and maybe it is a romantic idea.
But the idea is that the more tuned in you get to nature the more tuned in you
get to the movement of things on Earth the actual the life force on Earth.
Yeah and the more you begin to hear deeper parts of yourself when things quiet
down you can eat like you go in that floatation tank.
Yeah.
You know and when things really quiet down you can hear very deep parts of
yourself that normally you don't listen to at all.
Yeah.
So I think the idea is without all the distractions of modern life.
People were more tuned into a deeper instinct than we have now.
I think you're completely right.
I think that it's real possible that we're inundated by too much sensory
overload and that we're not relying on a lot of the instincts that we had to
rely on when we were hunter gatherers.
We're all we're doing is constantly hunting down animals and on the prowl for
your next meal and being really in touch with the Earth without any electrical
signals around us all the time without any Wi-Fi without any radio.
You know I like to think that that shit doesn't have any effect on me that I'm
not affected by Wi-Fi.
And that sounds like totally kooky talk.
Like what are you talking about man.
Scared a cell phone towers dude.
Are they zapping you.
I'm not saying that but what I am saying is there is something undeniably
different about where it feels when there's nothing.
If you go to a place that's in the mountains and very peaceful and you step
outside and there's no cell phone signals you don't I mean I guess you could
probably tune into the radio up there but it is not much.
Yes it's fucking quiet as shit to you're not getting any noise pollution not
getting city not.
It's a different feeling.
Now if that was life all the time and without even the distractions the
electronic distractions that that world sort of forces on you there's still some
who still you still have a TV still have.
If you were just in the woods all the time it's a totally different feeling.
Yeah and if you're in the woods now with a tracker who knows how to track
animals and they just start tracking animals it would seem like they're magical
probably in some of the things that they could do.
Yeah it's amazing so yeah man I think that that there is a difference.
I just saw this awesome visual depiction of why five you seen that it's a
picture of what Wi-Fi would look like if if if we could see it in the air and we
look like it looks just like an ocean like this rolling ocean of information
that we're all swimming around in right now.
That's so crazy.
It's crazy.
How long is it going to be before people forget about being psychic.
How long's it gonna be before you have some sort of Verizon chip in your head
that allows you to tune into the Internet.
Not long it doesn't seem like it's gonna be long right.
Not long ago within one hundred years.
That's gonna be reality I think within ten years.
Really.
Yes.
Like an operation I don't know about an operation I think within 10 years
they'll figure out a way to do it without an operation that's going to be so
strange.
And then it will be a world of psychics and then being psychic won't seem
strange at all because everyone will have the ability to tune in immediately to
all information on and available to anyone on earth or that's on the Internet
and you know some people going to complain about that.
Again I go through.
It everyone's thinking hell for lives.
Did you hear about the cyborg that just got beaten up in France a cyborg.
Yeah a guy's got.
There's a guy who one of the first ocular implants.
It's like connected to his bones it's a video camera that films things and he
was in a McDonald's in Paris and he goes in there the owner of the McDonald's
sees him tells him to take off his google glass he throws Google glasses and I
can't I can't take it off.
He brings medical papers with him to show people that it's an implant right.
But they didn't care and they you know they tried to rip it off his face but
it's connected to his bones.
Oh my God.
So the thing is got now the thing is got in it.
This if it starts malfunctioning it starts taking pictures of what's happening
when it malfunctions so he's got images of these French dudes who tried to rip
his face off.
So what happened to the he's filing charges with the police but they don't
they're not.
I mean it's like it's so weird.
The cops are like look we don't know how to handle cyborg crime.
Yeah.
Why would they say this is gonna be an emergent form of.
This is gonna be a new kind of hate crime which is people beating up cyborgs.
I think that's probably going to be the case.
I think especially if the limbs possessed superpowers like if you start getting
into like some six million dollar man realm where you decide to get your legs
chopped off and put these super bionic legs on you just jumping over buildings
and shirt and you know some guys might kick your ass.
The MillerCoors is crazy.
Good luck.
I know you have your cyborg legs.
They'll be really hard but if they hit you in the head you probably saw a human
head you know sucker punch you Ryan see it coming.
And then when you're out it's fuck you up.
Well this is like another problem.
This is a very off topic but this is another problem that's emerging is that
right now the disparity in wealth is indicated through people's possessions
their cars and their homes and their bling.
But in the future this disparity will be reflected in their physical appearance
so poor people who can't afford cyborg legs or cyborg arms or implants that
allow them to tune into the Internet they're going to have this incredible
disadvantage compared to people who can afford the implants.
You know and that's that's a real problem and you're really seeing evolution
there because those people who can't afford it are going to gradually slowly die
out.
Yeah I wonder man I really wonder if what these what we're seeing with these
people that possess this sort of psychic energy that tune into this psychic
Genji if everyone can do it we're just scared of even knowing that we can do it
so we don't look into it.
I mean why haven't I looked into it.
Why haven't I picked up a book on you know on psychic skills like there's books
on it supposedly teach you how to cultivate your psychic skills.
I haven't given them an honest try.
I haven't like sat down with them and been been completely objective.
So if I was making any judgment that psychic energy wasn't real I would be I
would be kind of a dick because it's not fair.
I really haven't tried.
I don't possess it but I haven't tried I haven't tried to cultivate it I haven't
done any of the work these guys had dames and and and Paul Smith.
They they have done their work and they say they can do it.
So I have to take their word for it but I think that I would like to see
something that really stands out for me.
I mean they had some good stories about stuff that works.
I would like to see something really stands out for me because the most
impressive display of psychic ability I've ever seen in my life was self
admittedly fake a better check that was the best display of psychic ability I
have ever seen in my life.
I do not know how he did it but I saw him make forks bend without barely
touching them.
I saw him make them twist up in a circle as he was guiding them his search that
as soon as I got down to find out how to do that and would they say well what
you do is you take a I mean there's a step by step guide to it.
Know it's possible.
Oh yeah.
You take the you take aluminum forks.
Right exactly like what he had.
And I mean this is according to the YouTube thing I didn't spend a lot of time
with it because you have to bend but you bend them right so you bend them and
they heat up.
So before you do your show you spend some time on these forks.
They get there by bending them they heat up they're looser and then that makes
them more bendable.
And I imagine that's it.
Ben this is not a if you google search a lot of what he did there is it shows
how to do it on the really.
Yeah.
Boy I would like to see that because I guess it's very possible I didn't really
completely thoroughly examine those force but I did click them together and they
were metal.
Clink clink and I picked them up I looked at them there were real forks whether
or not that was the fourth that actually made it into his hand when he did that.
I don't I mean there's guys that are really good with sleight of hand.
Yeah.
You know they're really good with it.
So that's possible but what's important is that he says it's bullshit all right.
He told us that it's all tricks.
He said I'm not psychic I have no psychic energy I can't tell you how I did this
because then I would reveal my sources but I'm not psychic.
I believe him.
I mean I don't have any reason to not believe him.
He seems like a very nice guy and it was very entertaining.
He's very very talented like I felt like we really got a treat because we got
like a very small intimate show with a master magician.
Yeah.
I mean he really is a master.
So it was really entertaining.
And then the fact that on top of that he was telling us that it was all just
tricks.
I found that to be like really fascinating.
Oh yeah.
He's like an uber skeptic.
Yeah.
And he's showing how it's so easy to manipulate people and he's showing how
you've got to be very careful when you get around somebody who tells you that
they can talk to dead people they can talk to invisible people because you get
all you get a lot of trouble with those folks.
Well he fooled scientists for four years.
Yeah.
They thought he had real psychic abilities for four years he fooled them.
Yeah it's amazing.
He made me much more skeptical but I'm.
But he still didn't.
You can't remove from me like experiences I've had where it's like I don't know
what that is but it's such an incredible coincidence that it seems beyond
coincidence.
I don't think he was trying to remove that.
I think what he was trying to do is it's show that you could B.S.
people yes you can.
And that's what he did.
He B.S.
people.
He's.
I don't think he's saying that you can't have these unique moments where where
something becomes apparent to you.
I think what he was trying to do was just show you that you can be tricked.
Yes.
And he was really good.
I mean really good at it.
Amazing at it.
We put coins over his eyeballs duct taped his face and he read the serial number
on a bill that was in my pocket.
I have no idea how he did that he wasn't even looking at it.
He was looking over there.
Yeah.
That was crazy man.
It was crazy a lot of what he did was crazy.
First of all he's 50 OK.
The idea that he could read it from my hand this far away.
I've got it I've got it a full arm's length away from his face that he can even
look over and read that serial number there's little tiny print on a dollar
bill.
They're going to read that from there.
That would be really hard to do.
But with duct tape over your face or coins over your eyeball yet and you're not
even looking at it I don't know how he did it.
I don't know how he did a lot of what he did.
It was amazing.
Yeah.
That girl when he picked her out of the audience and told her her dog's name.
That girl freaked out man.
She was like ready to cry.
She got emotional you could see her face.
Her jaw was and she wasn't a plant.
No she wasn't.
You know what I didn't know though man when I was getting all shrill of IRA
being a plant as I didn't know that in the beginning it had people write
information down and put it into an envelope.
Yeah but she didn't write about her dog.
Well I don't know that you know.
We know that we read her information.
She did write about her dog did read the information and the crew did.
We had we had her information read right.
Yes she didn't write a thing about her dog.
Well then
see she wrote the dogs.
Now women he got.
Did you read all that shit.
Yes
she wrote it and put it in her purse.
OK.
Do you know that there are pens and when you write things down these pens they
create an exact replica of that in a computer program and they work wirelessly.
See I didn't know that bit of information.
So my mind was just trying to decode what he did because it would've been
impossible.
Then it's like oh well we don't know maybe she used her own pen which in case
Look man she said he named initials and you would get that from someone writing
their name on a thing right.
Maybe he had a camera that was watching all of them.
Well I guess the point is like we're trying to figure out the specifics of what
he did but it's no question that what he did was tragic and it was a trick
because that's what he said.
He even had a camera behind me with a zoom lens and that's how he could read
that.
That's also he could react on the audience.
I mean who the hell knows.
Yeah there's no way to how far in advance did he know where we were going.
How long in advance did he know.
No idea
the location.
No idea how I got there.
Did he knew or know about it beforehand though before the call.
Possibly.
I don't think it's
we're we're we're trying to do here folks listening to this is trying to figure
out how the hell that guy did what he did what he did was masterful.
I mean everything about it even if it was tricks whatever it was it was amazing.
But having him say that it was tricks and it was so good it makes you really
call into question all the other psychic ability that people claim.
Well another thing that it does is it shines a light on how monstrous some
people are because imagine being such a sociopath that you use tricks like that
to get around people to show them that you have powers and then you charge them
money to let them communicate with their dead relatives your people who do that
for a living.
They are the most vile monstrous people on earth because they seek out the most
gullible humans who are desperate and morning and full of grief and guilt and
then they do a couple banter check tricks.
They get them convinced that they are magical and then they're like Yeah for a
thousand bucks or for a donation I'll let you say hello to your mom again.
Yeah.
He was very adamant about his his hate for that.
That type of price that minute bit of practice and what he does he calls himself
a mentalist and he's an entertainer and he's also a debunker.
He likes to debunk stuff you tell people that what he's doing is a trick.
Yeah.
Just so you know he's so good at it and he's telling you it's a trick.
So be careful because other people were probably tricking you too but they're
not going to be as ethical as he is.
All right.
He's a really cool guy man.
That was a real privilege it having him on the show.
But it is fun to imagine that he's just an evil Talib he's just an awesome real
psychic and that's how he makes a living by pretending he's not he's not.
He just goes there because he knows that if he tells people that being a
telepath is possible then everyone will have telepathic abilities and he'll he
won't you won't be special anymore.
I wonder if he used his own pen if he made them write their stuff down with his
pen.
That would explain a lot.
We don't.
I do know that they can do that now.
They have these special pens his computer pens and they dictate.
Well we don't know.
We got to get your pen back.
I mean I know you don't know you can do it wirelessly.
No but if you have like a I'm saying you want to get your magic wireless pen
back.
You don't want it true sir but I.
But I think that they gave their pen back anyway and people don't steal pens
when you fill out a rhyme especially if you say can I have my pen back please.
Like if the magic Pentagon to ask Can I have that blinking pen back that I gave
the lower the numbers says only megabytes are left.
Yeah.
I don't know what these tricks were but the important thing is that he says
there were tricks.
Yes.
And they were amazing.
Yeah but just because someone can emulate something doesn't mean that it's not
real.
But it made going to the Rhine Research Center feel so silly you know like me
standing in front of these things trying to figure out which one's gonna go off
next and totally getting nothing right.
Like thinking like maybe I've got this power.
And then this guy comes along that shows you like the craziest psychic shit
you've ever seen in your life.
And then just goes oh by the way it's all lies.
Yeah it's true man.
I mean there's a you can do a lot.
You could do a lot like think of Rasputin think of like grass butin this dirty
filthy guy who just comes into Russia says that he's a.
Psychic or a mystic and the next thing you know he's basically running Russia by
manipulating the leaders because he's convinced them that he has these powers.
I mean you can go far if you can convince people even something out about
Rasputin his giant cock his giant cock his cock that was so giant that cut it
off and bottled it.
They saved it forever.
You know a jar of formaldehyde.
And people go to a museum in Russia and look at it.
Yeah.
That's a Vegas caucus.
I've seen that just like eleven inches flaccid.
Yeah.
It's a giant hog.
It's a terrible thing to terrible evil looking dick.
Yeah it is.
Imagine going into a woman that you once loved just plunging into her.
I think that when the apocalypse happens it's going to wake up and break out of
that jar.
It's going to come out.
Is he taking his digs into sprout legs in the middle of the night.
No.
Remember that scene in aliens.
The second one.
Where.
What's his face.
Mad About You kept
the chick in the in the lab tried to get her contaminated with one of those
little face huggers.
It would be like it'd be like the face hugger.
It's going to grow some legs and Kravitz way around the laboratory till it
shoves its giant pickled cock in your mouth.
Giant giant pickled wizard.
Hundreds of years of formaldehyde soaked in this terrible green pulsating zombie
Dick with crab legs and antique jizz remnants pile and that's where it starts.
They open up the vault to try to rescue and you know it's a fucking swarm like a
beehive of bugs flying through the air that are all miniature little little
giant flying crab cocks and they just it just spreads it spreads like like a
like a virus aerial.
That would be the funniest apocalypse.
They're looking at it on a slide for the first time and it's a little tiny.
Evil cocks flapping their wings like what the fuck are we looking at.
They have to look at it like 100 x hundred times the size just to get it.
Or do we see two giant pickled cocks with wings next to my thigh.
Little tiny.
Yeah that's right.
The Sharknado man right.
Yeah.
That's.
I think that it's a that's a terrifying aspect of Rasputin.
Also the fact that they shot him several times and they kept Yeah poisoned them
they lost his voice and shot him.
I think due to the Dick that big as a special man you probably have a lot of
special tolerances.
You know it's a rigid human being.
If you got a big giant cock like that.
It's like the universe is like trying really hard to get you to breed you know
like.
Right.
We all know that like penis size no matter what anybody says it's means
something.
If it didn't mean anything it wouldn't bother if you dig a little it means
OK.
And you probably don't need a gigantic humongous one.
But if you have one you got that.
That's that's a big thing with people.
So when a guy like Rasputin comes along and he has a giant cock and he's
charismatic with a big giant cock.
Yeah.
It's it's a perfect storm of evil scary giant horse cock can communicate with
the dead.
That's all you need to take over Russia.
It is a real problem with people that were gullible.
You know that we want a balloon boy silly things in over the course of this
show.
One of the things that I've found is how many people get upset at you if you
don't believe the things that they believe.
Yeah well you feel embarrassed.
I mean yeah part of it is you feel embarrassed.
You want to defend it because you can't you know that if you're experiencing
some strange thing that some part of you is going to be skeptical.
And when you decide to believe in the strange thing then you become very
defensive.
It's embarrassing.
And that's that I think that's why sometimes you feel a little bit of sympathy
for some of these people but yes they've invested their lives into ideas that
they haven't fully investigated or explored in a real way.
Right.
It's really sad when you know knocking the legs out from under the table upon
which rests a person's entire paradigm.
That's a sad thing to see happen you're watching someone fight against that with
all their might.
Yeah.
And we're seeing that every week.
Yeah yeah.
Every week we're seeing some some person who believes something.
And I think somewhere along the line the show is becoming more about psychology
than it is even about these ideas.
Oh yeah man.
And it's one thing it's taught me is is that we can't let people who believe in
invisible unprovable things have any kind of power.
That's what it's showing me like.
Now a lot of these people you meet them there.
They don't have a church a congregation.
They haven't started a religion but you can see how someone like that if they
had power they would be incredibly dangerous if you're around somebody.
Yeah.
Well I think that people having power in that sense like the.
Presidential power or king type power is probably going to be a thing of the
past one day.
I think ultimately we're gonna realize that anybody that gets to control people
it's probably a bad idea.
It should all be like some sort of a group minded thing because if it's not then
you get led into wars and you get led into crazy situations bank takeovers and
bailouts and stuff.
I just saw a video on a Christian show which is a speech of Ronald Reagan when
he's president talking about how he believes that the end of the world is going
to happen in Israel based on biblical prophecy.
This is a president who controls nuclear weapons and he's free freely saying
this is what I believe it's better prophesies done in the old testament.
It's like no no your president you can't believe that you're not supposed to
believe that yes it's too weak an idea it's too weak an idea too.
And if you exhibit this week idea it should disqualify you from controlling
anything because it says it's a crazy persons thought.
So we have to re-evaluate.
Oh did we just let a charismatic crazy person run things.
Or did we really pick a wise leader right to the point when the point is a
leader can't really be a leader.
You need a bunch of people working with you need a hole and everyone says that.
But there's still a president.
It should there shouldn't be one.
There shouldn't be.
There's no fucking way one person should be running anything.
So yeah.
One person who believes crazy shit shouldn't be running anything you know well
shouldn't be running anything anybody.
No one should be running a goddamn country right.
No one it should be the entire country gets to vote on shit.
Yes.
You know what I think you can go a totally different sense of who people are
based on that.
Like read it.
Yeah.
Run the country with a rabbit.
Or Yeah I've be true to my or Twitter.
Imagine if you could vote on Twitter.
Yeah I would be amazed.
It would be incredible.
It would be amazing but also probably pretty easy to hack.
Maybe but why can we do our banking online then.
Right.
Good point.
You tell me you trust it with money you don't trust it with votes.
That's ridiculous.
Right sounds like you want to manipulate votes.
They can do it.
They can do pretty much everything online with banking and you're dealing with
millions and billions of dollars every day going back and forth including the
stock market.
Yeah so you're fine with all that but we can't vote.
Voting is too complicated.
That's the.
One man one vote.
What are you trying to say.
The whole system would have a bunch of hackers getting control.
You want a bunch of guys with Guy Fawkes masks.
One in this fucking country right.
They can't give it back to the people and they know that's what that would be.
They do it.
They can't do it.
You can never do it.
It'll never.
You'll never be able to vote.
Well I think you eventually will because I think the people that are in the
position to control things will eventually get phased out let new people come
in.
I just think it's inevitable because the generations that are coming up it's
going to be way harder to be as corrupt as the generations that are in power
that are just used to abusing it and having that kind of control.
You wouldn't want that.
Like if you could have the level of control of like a Julius Caesar I think it's
dangerous.
Things change.
Fuck no.
I would if it was like me or Hitler.
I'd say yeah.
You know I'm saying.
But it's never that and I think it's really what it should be is we should all
have ideas that we share and we should all have maybe things that we agree on or
disagree on or things that we can debate public discourse.
But ultimately it should be a vote should be 300 million people X amount of them
are over 18 whatever the age do we decide is it really should be probably 21.
Yeah.
And then from there on they get to make the choice.
Yeah but what if what if for example this voting happens in a country where
people believe in like Sharia law and believe that women should be covered in
burqas and that you know sort of that you cut off someone's hand who steals.
What if there's
red or white with a machine.
Really.
Would they convict her of Oh my God.
That's scary.
Right.
Read her mind.
It was admissible admissible in court that she actually had prior knowledge of
this crime.
That's incredible experience and knowledge.
That's incredible.
Not admissible not admissible in the U.S. Court while tell the story if people
listen to this I didn't hear what they just said is that there.
There is a woman in India that was convicted with this machine called an F M r.
I.
What does it stand for.
Functional MRI Magnetic Resonance imagery is what MRI stands for and that she
was convicted for murder because they knew that she had some sort of a memory of
the crime and they were able to read her mind find that wow.
Holy shit that's incredible.
That's cool.
I think that eventually we're going to have a hard drive on our brain and I
think we're gonna be able to record life in a way that looks exactly as if
you're live in it.
And I think you'll be able to watch it and experience it.
I think first of all probably visual.
But then as people the technology gets better and better and people get more
advanced.
We'll figure out a way to experience everything too.
Would be like black and white TV.
They started out it was just a black and white television right.
Then also there was color HD stereo stereo sound worth those winds whistling
behind human TV today are incredible.
Yeah but they start out as big stupid wooden box with this dumb little tube in
the middle of it that look like shit.
It was rounded like a fishbowl.
I think that first they're gonna start out with video.
It's gonna be you in the video and have some sort of an audio and you got to be
a play it back.
Google Glass.
Something along those lines but it'll be all the time and you'll be able to
access it.
You'll have a giant like 18 trillion terabyte hard drive in your head.
Yeah and you'll be able to access your entire life.
So we're gonna have to people are going to be able to read your minds by just
taking it out.
Yeah and like we'll see what Duncan was doing up beaten off the tranny porn.
Where are you.
Duncan yelling ball gags and tranny porn.
Sure they'll be able to find out what you saw.
No way.
There was nothing wrong with that man.
And the more we realize the quicker we realize there's nothing wrong with that
the happier Robbie but the.
The.
The point is that they're going to be it was gonna be a moot point.
I think everyone's going to be psychic.
Yes exactly.
I mean yeah for sure people if you look at how we already are psychic and not
connected to our heads yet more certainly way more psychic today than people
were that were living in like you know 15 20.
Yes.
You know what we can do now is call it what it call what you will.
The connection is always on and it's much more powerful and we can do things
incredible like talk to people that are on the other side of the world in real
time.
I mean what is it.
I am pregnant misquoted but didn't Asimov say technology that is an
and a technology.
I'm going to butcher this quote but it's nothing like a technology an advanced
enough technology would be indistinguishable from magic.
Yes that's exactly the quote.
So that's so that's the idea which is that if you were to go back and tell
people yes we use wireless signals to show us where we're going.
We use wireless signals to communicate with people on the other side of the
planet.
We use wireless signals to control cars.
We use wireless signals to do everything.
People be like What are you talking about how is that even possible.
But now it's real.
And so I'm sure that in the future once technology becomes more part of us than
we all become cyborgs then in that way the notion of being able to mentally
merge with a person won't seem insane at all.
In fact you will be able to merge with the consciousness of the planet.
There'll be some kind of emotional Internet where you can empathic we
technologically merge with all human beings and experience the way the entire
planet feels.
I think you're absolutely right.
I think that we're starting to feel the beginnings of this with the Internet
that we're experiencing today.
I think the Internet is joining people today in a way that we've never
experienced before.
And it's just begun.
And I think the next step is probably going to be lot more immersive.
Yes.
And that next step might deal with real time video and audio from person to
person you might be able to access people's actual experiences as they're taking
place.
Sure and then there's going to be designer augmented realities where you can
have you can download upgrades just a normal reality like make your reds redder
yeah make the colors deeper let's turn it turn let's let's enhance smells and
they'll be like well let's change smells all together this turns the smell of
far into roses.
So from now on you're not going to smell any bad things.
And that's going to be what starts happening as we begin to enhance our reality
technologically which I've heard in Google Glass.
It's already happening like the one thing that they're desperately trying to
keep out of Google Glass is facial recognition.
But someone's already hacked it.
So it does that because the last thing you want is for a stranger to be able to
walk up to you with Google Glass scan your face go do a google image search and
come up with like Oh hey Ted do you remember me.
Really.
That's a problem as you like wait do I really know you or are you just using the
Internet.
So they don't want that to happen.
But the thing about it is they're already going to hack it.
That happens and then you can have like a yelp for people.
You know what I mean so that when you're doing facial scans for people you could
see hanging above them douchebag rapist or pedophile or whatever.
So people are going to be cursed with this cloud that whatever is about them in
the cloud will be around them and you can you could change that you can upgrade
it if you want.
You can make it so that assholes always have flies swarming around them you know
to avoid them.
That's a great idea.
Yeah.
If technology really can do that and we start judging each other based on our
experiences.
But you're gonna have like you're gonna have to look at a guy's record to like.
OK.
Who gave you one star.
Oh look at this guy he's an asshole.
Sure.
You could tell.
You know we already can't do that like you just takes a second.
Yeah I can already get your name and go on your Facebook account and within 10
seconds figure out if you're a douchebag.
Yeah.
I mean how many times you gonna to someone's Twitter and you go Oh I know what's
going on in your head.
Yeah.
Quick right away.
That's sort of psycho in a way.
Yeah.
I mean it's communicative and essentially the idea of psychic is it cuts out all
the middlemen and you get right to the information.
Yeah yeah yeah.
It's a it's a form of technologically enhanced connectivity that's never existed
as far as we know on this planet until today and it's only going to get more and
more intense and everyone's you know this is part of the thing where ever it's
like oh god the NSA they're watching everything I do there's no more privacy
it's like oh you have no idea.
You're so lucky right now if you exist right now this is the last era of
privacy.
It's already there's hardly any privacy if you do something dumb enough on a
city bus the entire planet will see if you if you murder someone.
It's so much more difficult to get away with it today than it's ever been
before.
Yeah but you can't commit a crime you commit a crime if you just do something
embarrassing if you like if you try to take a burning tequila shot and set your
face on fire within 30 minutes the entire planet might be looking at that event.
So privacy is already going the way of the dinosaur.
But in 15 years you will not be able to go outside.
Do you think to be out for it.
Do you think that's going to cause a convergence though a real convergence where
people have real empathy for other people because they're experiencing they're
paying their feelings all the time.
I think that if anything positive can come out of this connection that human
beings are experiencing it's going to be that are going to realize somewhere
along the line that we're going to all be a lot better off if everybody's happy
and there must be a way if you can get two people to be happy or for people to
be happy.
Why can't you get four million.
What is missing.
Well at what point in time does it become.
Does everybody lose value.
Is it 4000 is it forty thousand four hundred thousand.
There's a number where people stop giving a shit about certain people they read
about the newspaper.
If there's only four of you one of you dies everybody gets sad.
Yeah but if this four million of you like we lost another one today hey this
fucking four million people don't worry about it.
Yeah right.
Man Well I think that's one part of it.
I think the other part of it is there's going to just be people even more
addicted and negativity and like the NAB think so yeah I think the Nancy Grace
show is gonna be really hard to watch because you'll be able to emotionally tune
into it and guarantee Nancy Grace if you like.
Here's the way it feels to be an eight year old getting strangled to death.
People want to experience those dark things too.
But I think ultimately it's the ultimate device of peace because when let's say
the president of Iran sits down with the president of Israel and they
telepathically merge minds so that one can experience the totality of the other
person's life and what they whatever their religion is and whatever their ideas
are if those things merge thinking like oh shit we're exactly the same.
We really are the same.
That's that's the problem.
Yeah yeah the problem is if you live their life you would have a very similar
way of looking at the world as they do and they lived yours they would probably
have all your experiences all your hopes and dreams and loves and conquests and
failures all that shit together makes you.
And unless someone is you.
It's hard it's hard for them to understand you.
But when we all can see each other it's gonna get real weird.
Man it's hard for you to understand you much less somebody else but you still
you know where else it's going to ruin it's going to ruin the meat industry
because the first thing PETA is gonna do is slap one of these brainwave devices
on a cow that's about to get slaughtered.
Send that up on the Internet be like Go ahead eat a cheeseburger.
But first experienced this insane terror that that meat felt right before it got
murder.
I think you're right it's going to be a weird world.
I think there's gonna be a lot of weird things we're gonna be able to experience
a lot of weird ways and we're gonna be able to be in touch with each other.
And also getting hacked our minds are gonna be able to get hacked and that's
another scary thing in the way that sometimes you wake up and someone will be
and you'll have like six emails from your friends being like hey asshole you got
fished.
I don't want to buy a purse.
Please stop trying to sell me purses in the same way.
You might wake up in like your brain has been hacked and implanted all over your
brain as the desire to go eat a cheeseburger to like go on a certain website.
That's another scary thing.
Yeah.
Are we go with this episode.
We just have a few little bits to hear.
What do you have to greatest you haven't been the right.
Right.
But I said it earlier I talked about the run as to
what you mean what you said is great.
Kind of do it as if you haven't been there yet.
Okay.
So I'm headed to this place called the Rhine Research Center and it's the gold
standard for the scientific study of the paranormal.
Yeah I've heard of them they make the cards they've been studying the paranormal
since the 1930s.
So I'm going to go there and see what they can show me.
What kind of scientific proof they could demonstrate that apparently they can
show you all the different ways that they can measure psychic ability and we're
gonna we're gonna try a few out.
Yeah man they're the ones who invented those psychic cards at those squiggly
lines in the square in the circle.
They're the ones that came up with that test.
Yeah.
Well apparently they say some people have innate abilities.
Some people don't.
Some people you can you can sort of cultivate their their abilities.
Some people can't.
Sure I believe it.
We'll see.
I'm open minded.
I'll go check it out.
Yeah.
They're very respected.
Good luck.
So.
Anyone looking to get more information on any of these subjects we're talking
about.
Go to sci fi dot com there's like clips and videos go check that out.
Spell it because they spell it.
Yeah s y f y dot com people look was you stupid Sean.
There's not even science fiction.
You're right but it's as s y f y dot com they got you on a technicality.
So yeah it's not the sci fi channel anymore like as an only science fiction.
But it's still pronounced sci fi and you have a right to be upset at me.
I understand that if I wasn't me and I was watching this and I wanted to see
Battlestar Galactica I'd be like was the fear factor do Sean right.
I'm looking to watch some Battlestar Galactica some science fiction right but
it's not just science fiction.
Like you know that one channel that sticks to their name while learning channel
that's all about learning as.
If you have now.
So I like people wrestling pigs.
What do they have on now it's all reality shows learning channel is like.
Well what do they have.
Honey honey boo boo's on the Learning Channel horn.
What are we learning.
People are really stupid as fuck and I'm learning I love honey.
Borders is on blurring show why hoarders.
You say hoarders I think hoarders isn't hoarders on the arts and entertainment.
There is on arts and entertainment.
Right.
Because I'm an art or an entertainment both.
So you know I don't know man.
I don't.
I don't know about this.
This psychic ability thing I think we have to wrap it up now but my my take on
it is I did not feel like in doing the show that it disproved anything to me.
It did prove to me that there's guys like Bana check who are absolutely
masterful at doing what he did.
However he did it.
He claims that it's a trick and he's not psychic.
I believe him.
What he did was amazing though.
So I learned that there's people like that.
I was really blown away by his abilities but I didn't.
It didn't take away from me the possibility that a guy like Ed dames can remote
view or their guy like Paul Smith can remove you.
I couldn't do it.
I didn't see evidence of it but there's enough there for me enough anecdotal
evidence enough stories of these guys seeing things that turned out to be real
that I would be foolish if I dismissed it without actually learning how to do
it.
And that was one of the important things so I'm going to leave it at that.
I don't know whether or not psychic energy is real but I am incredibly impressed
impressed.
Say again I don't know if psychic energy is real or psychic abilities real but
I'm incredibly impressed at Banamex ability to fake it and it deems descriptions
of how it works.
So that's where I'll leave it.
Cool.
I'm in the middle on it.
I'm all over the place.
I know people out there try to develop their abilities.
I should too.
You know I don't know what's wrong with me why I don't want to like sit down or
read a book on it.
I really need to figure out what's what's wrong with me that I don't want to
give it a chance.
God when I was a kid I used to read those books all the time.
Did they work.
No.
But like I would.
I remember reading that you could sit and like if you stare at the back of
someone's neck you could make them look at you Savi riding in the car and just
staring at the back of my brother's neck trying to get into turnaround it work.
I mean there's cardio shit i absolutely tired of my shit and he would turn
around anyway to punch me.